[Music]
hello dear friends and thank you for
joining us once again here at our
program I'd like to know it is always an
honor and a privilege for us to
participate in this program and answered
your questions that you send to us every
week I am delighted to be with Pastor
Sten Bor in the program and we want to
remind you that you can get in the fun
of answering the questions or sending us
your questions to the following address
which is TV at Sam tv.org and we are
honored as always to be able to receive
those questions and we do our best to
answer them as we receive them so please
have a little bit of patience know that
we are working in getting to your
question and answering in the program so
Pastor bour as we are going to start I
want to ask you to lead us into prayer
as we want to open God's word and we
need his guidance and leading all right
let's pray Father in heaven we come
boldly to the throne of grace because we
come in the powerful and Almighty name
of Jesus Amen as we begin this program
we realize that our knowledge is so
limited yes we know very little but you
are omnicient you know all and so we
recur to you as we begin this program
asking that you will be with us that you
will Enlighten our minds that you will
direct our thoughts and our words and
that this program might be a blessing to
those who have asked these questions
amen we depend fully and totally on you
in this program and we pray this in
Jesus name amen amen amen pastor we have
a question from uh Patrick we uh
unfortunately don't know where he's from
but we want to encourage our friends who
who are watching that they can send us a
location we love to know where where you
know where we reaching with our program
amen so the question is this there
pastors and he says thank you for this
beautiful program he has changed my life
significantly God bless you all I am
writing you from Johannesburg South
Africa I stand corrected he did put it
there in the email where he's writing us
for and I forgot about that from
Johannesburg South Africa with uh what a
wonderful thing my question is with
regards to the relationship between
angels and the Holy Spirit as far as
function is concerned does the Holy
Spirit work through the ministration of
Angels or does he carry out his
functions on his own how does the Holy
Spirit function compared to that of the
Angels thank you for the
opportunity and uh well we have a good
question how does the Angels work do
they work Under The Guiding of the Holy
Spirit or they have a separate work and
the Holy Spirit work by itself how does
it work how can we answer this question
well this is a very broad question that
I've been studying for
decades um in fact our next
newsletter which is going to come out in
probably about six to eight weeks uh the
title is Reflections on the great
delegator oh amen for that and I answer
this question fully in about 20 pages in
the article that I wrote the fact is
that the angels are more important than
what we generally
realize uh several years ago I um I was
reading the episode where God came and
spoke to Cain and he said to him if you
do well will you not be accepted if you
do not do well sin lies at the gate
right um I was reading that in Genesis
and I decided that I would go to the
spirit of Prophecy and see what Ellen
White said about it now in Genesis it
says that uh god Jehovah God spoke to
Cain those
words but Ellen White states that God
can descended to send an angel to speak
those words to Cain very very
interesting uh and I found time and
again
what events are attributed to God in the
Old Testament are really attributed to
God but Angels actually perform the
work um for example the Bible says that
God took the chariot wheels off of
Pharaoh's chariots yeah Ellen White says
that Angels grabbed the wheels and took
them off um you know the Bible says that
God brought down the walls of
Jericho Ellen White says that God
through the Angels brought down the
wheels of Jericho mhm and so I found
this time and again time and again in
the Old Testament that God accomplishes
his work here through the ministration
of the Angels uh I have a statement here
very powerful statement in Ministry of
healing page
417 the Bible shows us in his high and
holy place not in a state of
inactivity not in silence and
solitude but surrounded by 10,000 time
10 thousand and thousands of thousands
of holy beings all waiting to do his
will through these
Messengers he is in active communication
with every part of his
Dominion by his Spirit he is everywhere
present but then notice what she says
through the agency of his spirits his
spirit and his angels He ministers to
the children of men above the
distractions of the earth he sits
enthroned all things are open to his
Divine survey and from his great and
calm eternity he orders that which his
Providence sees best powerful statement
yes um you know Ellen White time and
again in her writings as you will see in
this article the article is actually on
uh Ezekiel chapter 1 that Vision that
appears to be so confused using whe a
wheel within a wheel and you know
there's these beings that are flashing
around like lightning and they're full
of eyes and they have four faces and you
know it it almost sounds like it can
never be interpreted right but once you
interpret the symbols you see how God
administrates University uh the universe
God is a
delegator and the key is in Revelation
chapter 1 where it says that the father
gives a message to the son the the son
gives it to the spirit he who has an ear
let him hear what the spirit says to the
churches right and the spirit gives it
to the angel the angel gives it to John
John sends it to the churches and the
churches are supposed to share it with
the world so God has a chain of command
he he operates like the military yeah if
you please uh but many times we think
that that everything that everything God
does
directly uh you know it reminds me of
the story of the Centurion mhm you know
uh he had h a servant who was ill and so
uh he comes to Jesus and he says you
know uh I have this servant who is ill
will you heal him and Jesus says yeah
I'll come to your house and heal him
yeah and the Centurion who's a pagan
he's a Roman uh he says to you don't
have to come to my house you know he
says just speak the word and it will be
done you know and I used to think
because I didn't read the story
carefully I used to think that somehow
when Jesus said let him be healed his
word flew through the air and you know
entered into the servant and healed him
but that's not the case Jesus spoke the
word and then uh the angel flew there
and the angel brought healing um and the
and the Centurion understood this yes
because he says I am also a man that has
soldiers under me and I tell them do
this and do that and and they obey my
word MH so he understood how the
mechanism Works I'd like to read Ellen
White uh commenting on this particular
story this is much much more profound
than what we've realized I've always
said that we need to have another
fundamental belief belief on the
ministry of angels right in the
Adventist Church right because the Bible
is saturated with with the ministry of
angels and it's through them that God
accomplishes his will here on Earth uh
this is her comment on the
Centurion now when Jesus had entered
capernium a centurion came to him
pleading with him saying Lord my servant
is lying at home paralyzed dreadfully
tormented and Jesus said to him I will
come and heal him the Centurion answered
and said Lord I'm not worthy that you
should come under my roof but only speak
a word and my servant will be
healed now he explains how it works for
I also am a man of under Authority
having soldiers under me and I say to
this one go and he goes and to another
come and he comes and to my servant do
this and he does it when Jesus heard it
he marveled and said to those who
followed um assuredly I say to you I
have not found such great faith not even
in Israel now Ellen White explains this
in Desire of Ages Plage
316 she's quoting the the uh
Centurion as I represent the power of
Rome and my soldiers recognize my
authority as
Supreme so do you represent the power of
the infinite God and all created things
obey thy voice Thy word you can command
the disease to depart and it shall obey
thee you can summon thy Heavenly
Messengers and they shall impart healing
virtue M speak but the word and my
servant shall be healed
mhm so that's the way that it works the
Holy Spirit Works through the ministry
of angels and it's interesting I did
research uh in uh the writings of Ellen
White on the relationship between the
spirit and the angels Ellen White says
that through the Angels the holy spirit
is enabled to work upon human
hearts uh so uh it's not it's not that
the angels have the power they are they
are the cables if you if you wish
through whom the Holy Spirit uh Works uh
so so the answer to this question is
that the Holy Spirit Works through the
ministration of the Angels upon human
minds and human hearts amen amen Pastor
I think that these um you know this
question really it's an important one to
ask for us to know how we can relate
to God through the agency of the angels
and how the Holy Spirit really is the
third person of the godhead who is
actively working for our behalf on Earth
and uses the angels as the as you said
as the me as The Messengers as the
agency to act upon the blessings that he
has for us I think that the verse for
example in Matthew
1810 makes a lot of sense with this
understanding even more so uh what he
says there Christ to speaking to to the
people take heed that you do not despise
one of the little ones for I said it to
you that in heaven their Angels always
see the face of my father who is in
heaven and you know with that thought El
white mentions in great controversy when
she actually quotes this verse in great
controversy page 512 the following
sentence he says the Angels appointed to
minister to the children of God have at
all times access to his presence so is
not that the you know so how do how do
the Angels who are physically with
assigned to each individual person you
know a guardian angel how can they be
always in the presence of God through
the Holy Spirit the holy spirit is that
agency that they can have continually
presence before God and and this is sort
of what makes a lot of sense and you
know when we study these verses and we
can actually see that this the the
connection the union of God through the
Holy Spirit through the angels to
minister to us is just as just mentioned
a chain of command but ultimately the
honor and glory is to the father because
like Jesus submits to the father and
that's sort of how it is that's why the
Angels don't take any credit for
themselves you know they're okay being
the eners of God but they are Servants
of God the Father they're only doing
yeah what God tells them the will of God
so the honor and glory is for God Amen
and and they
Delight in obeying the orders of God uh
uh you know that statement that I
mentioned about the uh Holy Spirit
working through the Angels is found in
youth instructor uh July 5
1894 and I want to read that through the
ministry of the
Angels the holy spirit is enabled Amen
to work upon the mind and the Heart of
the human agent to draw him to Christ
who has paid the ransom money for his
soul that the sinner may be rescued from
the slavery of sin and Satan and I found
time and again in the writings of Ellen
White yeah that what scripture
attributes to the spirit the Angels
perform it amen uh the Angels Enlighten
the Mind Ellen White says yes the Angels
keep us from from giving into sin uh you
know everything that is attributed to
the Holy Spirit the angels are
accomplishing it through of course the
power of the Holy Spirit um the the holy
spirit is kind of like the power plant
exactly and the angels are the
wires that's a good a good analogy
Pastor I think that makes a a lot of
sense and I think that is why you know
the the Bible tells us that we have a a
a war against principalities and powers
in the high places the angels of God are
to protect us but when we neglect that
communion when we are not asking the
Lord to to really be with us to protect
us through the Angels evil angels come
around and those are the ones that if
we're not connected with the source of
power they can lead us into temptation
and to sin and it actually um they
separate us from our power which is in
in the power of Holy Spirit through the
angels that work in our behalf so uh
thank you for the answer I hope that
this has helped uh Patrick and again uh
we look forward also for the newsletter
article that's coming in the near future
uh we want to invite people to subscribe
to our newsletter I think it's going to
be a blessing especially that article
that's that newsletter article only
deals with Ezekiel 1 wow but it doesn't
it doesn't deal with all of that well I
mentioned the Centurion all those things
uh because this is a very broad subject
right of course and Ellen White has a an
incredibly remarkable statement yeah
where she says that all the Miracles of
Christ yeah were performed by the power
of God through the ministration of the
Angels mhm all of them she says in
spirit of Prophecy uh so so once again
the Angels were the emissaries of Christ
yeah to bring healing to people who were
ill amen it is a a awesome thought that
God can have give the power to one Angel
and that's what he said one angel will
be enough to destroy I me know many
things if it's necessary one Angel
killed all the um children uh of the the
you know first borns in Egypt you know
one Angel so the power of an Angel it's
it's incredible because it's a power of
God given to that particular Angel so we
have to keep that in mind I like the
power plant illustration yeah because
the cables that take the power they can
say we healed the sick guy no yeah the
power came from the power plant from the
Holy Spirit through the conduit of the
Angel exactly that's a good analogy
Pastor I like that and you you don't
know about Electric too much huh no you
do all right well let's continue to the
next question comes from Allan and from
Washington State and his question is the
following question does Romans 912 I
mean does Romans 9 14 to 23 teaches
predestination been trying to read the
Bible commentary several Bible
translations but can seem to be able to
put the pieces together I know that I
know from Romans 211 that God shows no
impartiality but here he comes Paul out
of the left field and WR things that can
be easily reconstructed why the Bible
continually says that it is God who
hardens the
heart so this is the question that Alan
has and Pastor what can we say about
this particular passage in scriptures of
Romans well the bottom line is that um
in the book of Exodus where it speaks
about Pharaoh hardening his heart
mhm um the the it's it's expressed in
both ways it says that God hardened
Pharaoh's heart but it also says that
Pharaoh hardened his heart so some texts
say that God Did It others say that that
um Pharaoh did it uh there's no
contradiction uh The Sun Shines on ice
and melts it right The Sun Shines on
clay and hardens it mhm the sun is not
to
blame to blame Is What It Shines on
right and so the light of God shines
upon Pharaoh right fullness of light
through the plagues Etc exactly and what
does pharaoh do hard his heart he
hardens his heart in the Bible what God
permits is attributed to God even though
God didn't do it right because God has
um a permissive will and a causitive
will yeah permissive will like in the
story of Job God allows Satan to test
job right right but clearly it says in
chapter 1 and two that it's Satan who is
causing all the ills yeah but when you
get to chapter 42 it says all the evil
that God brought upon him so you know at
the end of the book it says that God
brought upon him at the beginning of the
book it says that the devil is doing it
so there's no contradiction
um when it comes to the issue of
predestination this passage in Romans
9:14 to
23 uh you know it's it has to do with
God's forn knowledge
correct you know God forn knows what's
going to
happen uh he does not predestine what is
going to happen in other words he does
not determine what is going to happen a
prime example is the story of Jacob and
Esau which is brought up here in Romans
9 through1 right um you know God said uh
from before they were born uh the older
is going to serve the younger so in
other words the younger is going to get
the birth right that's exactly how it
happened yeah but but it's not that God
is determining it that way but God knew
the character that each of them would
develop and on the basis of that he
chose Jacob and he rejected Esau he did
not do it arbitrarily right uh also in
the case of Judas exactly I was say that
name yeah because of Judas Pastor I just
took it from my mouth I was going to
tell you he is a prime example he had uh
the Bible says that the Lord knew he was
going to be you know the one to to to to
betray him but Christ worked with him so
much and even till the the last moment
when he was washing his feet Spirit
prophecy clearly tells us that Judas
felt compelled to confess his sin when
he saw Jesus you know washing his feet
but he hardened his heart he did not
want to Humble himself and recognize and
then those those feelings that were
attracted to to to confess his sin to
the Lord he put away for the for you
know because they came for a moment he
put them away he put in his mind I do
not see any future with Jesus this is
not the master I want to serve I don't
want to be you know serving somebody who
who has a a a kingdom that is about
giving of himself and he called and told
himself I've been deceived this is not
the Son of God so he hardened his heart
even though the light was shining even
though the love of God
was presenting to him as the evidence of
God but there like you said because his
pride his selfishness his desire of
money that made him Harden his heart and
he decided to reject Christ and the
enemy filled his mind he he was demon
possessed in that moment and he went and
betrayed the Lord so that's a prime
example as you were mentioning you know
and I was just thinking as you were
sharing that's an example that really
tells us how a person can Harden the
heart and can
be uh you know I guess also predestined
because it says the Bible speaks of his
friend betraying him but it's not
because the Lord directed Judas to act
that way he just fora that he he knew
that from the forand yeah and uh and you
know it's interesting uh to to notice in
second Thessalonians chapter 2 there's
an example uh where it says that the
Antichrist is going to deceive most of
the world MH and it says that God will
send them upon a strong delusion
delusion he will send upon God will send
upon them a strong illusion so does God
go around deluding people no no it's
because it says clearly that they chose
to believe a lie yeah rather than the
truth so it's based on their choice you
know time is just about up but I'd like
to read one text that makes it very
clear Romans chapter 8 and verse 29
Romans 8 and verse 29 Pastor I can wait
for you I mean it's a powerful verse for
whom he fornew he also predestined to be
conformed to the image of his son that
he might be the firstborn among many
Brethren and also verse 30 moreover whom
he predestined these he also called whom
he called these he also Justified and
who he justified these he also glorified
amen you know verse 29 says for whom he
forew right other words he knew what the
choice was going to be yeah by the way
it's the word pre prognosis prognosis
yeah we get the word prognos
in other words because God forew right
who was going to receive Christ he
predestined that person that's right but
God did not
say saved and lost no he forew who would
choose to be saved and who would choose
to be lost exactly uh but he did not
determine it amen amen and that's kind
of the important thing you know that the
Lord is not determining or or or or
outcome we determine their outcome he
just knows about it and that's how he
can foretell who will be lost who will
be saved well we thank you again uh for
being with us we appreciate your prayers
your support and continue to please keep
us in your prayers as our ministry
depends on you and depends on your
commitment to the Lord as well so that
we pray that you will uh continue to
allow us to be of service to you in our
programs in our ministry may God bless
you looking forward to hearing you again
or seeing
you guys again in a near future through
i' like to know
[Music]